you know back in the 90s there was a
first-person shooter it was called blood
and when you got two handguns it was
called guns akimbo so I can't hear this
title without thinking of that can't
hear this title without getting blasted
back thirty years or at least
twenty-five twenty-five years that's
fair
[Music]
guns akimbo so guns akimbo stars Daniel
Radcliffe in the preface the premise
just sounds like it promises a lot of
massacre and mayhem
Daniel Radcliffe he is a fellow nerd he
also gets knocked out and these guys
bolts guns to his hands so that he gets
entered into this livestream game online
that's is the fight to the death which I
was like it when a movie goes that route
with that premise you know I mean the
guns bolted to the hands thing that's
new but the whole yeah and the president
are not too distant future murder each
other on live TV or streaming on the
internet thing I enjoy that because it
shows somebody in the creative process
they understand humanity a couple
thousand years ago we had the Roman
Colosseum but we've changed we've
evolved now we haven't the coliseums
changed just become more digital but we
still love the evisceration of our
fellow human beings we are as Kaew said
you will now answer to the charge of
being a grievously savage race and it's
important to remember I'm not just a fan
I'm also a member and as a member of
this grievously Savage race I'm not
gonna lie to you I wanted more mayhem
and shoot him up with Daniel Radcliffe
sounds superficial I know but from its
premise alone that's kind of what the
movie promises you you don't have to
give me that if the movie takes me along
for the ride of Daniel Radcliffe's
characters gross but it doesn't and
that's a problem so if it's not gonna do
that plus the stylistic nature of how
this movie opened up it kind of lends
itself to being like hey audience this
is what the movie is stylistics shoot
him up and bloody murder
sweet give me that but it doesn't really
stick the landing on that and I'm till
the last half-hour
tell them no it's Daniel Radcliffe
running from things I understand you got
a massage him into it he's he's not a
killer by trade right when I saw that
each gun had 50 rounds into it I was
like 50 rounds goes pretty fast a
hundred rounds also goes fast so huh how
they gonna do that will they do it by
having him run from people for a large
section of this movie at least in the
movie they they address the fact that
that's kind of boring it being a
production they're trying to optimize
hits and they all agree that someone
just running from the fight that's not
interesting I'm glad they recognized in
the movie that it says boring as it
probably is for us watching the movie
now the one daniel radcliffe's going
after
in this movie her name is NYX played by
Samara weaving and at first I was like I
would have preferred someone who's like
the Terminator like you get scared when
they come on screen wasn't really like
that with her but by the end she was a
sympathetic character so I got what they
were going for so she actually totally
did work worked more than bolting guns
to a super vegan pacifists hands because
that's a problem in this movie that's
one of the reasons this movie was just
kind of slogging along for a bit for a
stylistic as it was you attach guns to
the hands of a super vegan pacifist he's
still not gonna use the guns he just now
can't use his hands granted it made for
some humorous moments when he's trying
to put on his pants piss or eat but I
have to think that's the reason they
bolted guns to his hands because
otherwise she just he acted like he
didn't have guns bolted to his hands he
just ran from everything so what's the
point of having guns bolted to his hands
and you know what I know right we all
know the premise of this movie is going
to be at first he doesn't want to shoot
people and then by the end he digs deep
he finds the stones alright now he's
gonna shoot people which means the last
half hour this movie is actually pretty
awesome and that's where the hundred
rounds between the two guns that's where
they go but still I argue the whole guns
being bolted to his hands gimmick thing
is just that it's a gimmick so that's my
point this super pacifist
bullet guns to his head it doesn't
matter you know you could have the
entire arsenal in Neos jacket bolted to
every limb he has and his dick for good
measure he's still not gonna use it this
might be based off a graphic novel I
don't know it seems like it would be
though doesn't look like it but they do
actually have people having a fight with
hammers to MC Hammer actually it wasn't
MC Hammer it was super freak but same
song so when the young guns akimbo is
hit-and-miss
all in one movie it has some chuckle
worthy moments of humour not all of it
landed I like the style of the movie but
for a movie called guns akimbo about
guns being bolted to someone's hands
should have had much more guns akimbo
it's not like this is the not POV
version of hardcore Henry or anything
it's not like that it does leave it open
for a sequel and I'm looking forward to
the sequel because now that this dude
learned how to kick
ass let's just start that out in the
sequel from the beginning but for now
guns akimbo I'll say probably be a
better time if I were a little drunk
yeah it's a party all right so guns
akimbo have you seen it what did you
think about it son Amazon Prime I think
I'm 90% sure as Amazon Prime but
whatever you thought about it comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]